OKAY, THE TRAFFIC IS REALLY
HEAVY OVER THERE,
SO IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO GET INTO THAT,
AND THEN THERE'LL
BE REALLY SOME THINGS
TO GET MAD ABOUT.
DENSE TRAFFIC.
OH, GREAT.
I'M STUCK BEHIND A [bleep]--
WHAT IS THAT, A TRACTOR?
DON'T DRIVE A TRACTOR
ON THE STREET IN TRAFFIC.
JUST SO I'M CLEAR,
IT'S NOT ILLEGAL
TO GIVE SOMEONE
THE FINGER, RIGHT?
BECAUSE I'M THINKING OF GIVING
SOMEONE THE FINGER.
BUT IT'S NOT ILLEGAL, RIGHT?
YOU DON'T GET ARRESTED
FOR THAT, DO YOU?
- NO.
- HURRY UP, GRANDMA!
[horn honks]
THEY'VE BEEN DOING CONSTRUCTION
ON THIS STREET FOR FOUR MONTHS!
ENOUGH!
I MEAN IT'S AN IMPORTANT
DRAINAGE PROJECT,
I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT IT'S INFURIATING.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M REALLY
FEELING ALL THE ANGER
I NEED TO HERE,
BUT I'LL TRY AGAIN.
I SAW PLENTY OF CARELESSNESS,
BUT NONE OF IT WAS HARMFUL
TO ME, PERSONALLY,
UNTIL, FINALLY, I GOT LUCKY.
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS?
THIS GUY'S PASSING ME
ON A TWO-LANE STREET.
[horn honks]
HEY, JACK-WHACK.
THAT'S FOR YOU,
THE MIDDLE FINGER!
EAT IT!
OH.
OH, OKAY.
HERE WE GO.
IT IS ON.
COME WITH ME.
ROAD RAGE IN ACTION.
HEY, YOU DON'T PASS SOMEBODY
ON A TWO-LANE STREET!
THAT'S NOT SAFE.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
OH, AH, NO, NEVER MIND.
IT'S FINE.
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY,
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY.
I JUST DIDN'T THINK IT WAS SAFE
TO GO ON A--PASS--OH.
HEY, EXCUSE ME.
UH, WAIT A MINUTE.
PLEASE DON'T GET IN MY CAR.
HEY, WAIT A MINUTE.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT!
WHERE YOU GOING?
PLEASE COME BACK!